hello and i'm not doing it what's up reject nation
greg john and this guy ace i was like oh let's get
a star wars expert on here hated everything
he did last time he was here and that's all
his positive comments and i was like fine you
can come back it's your privilege to be here
you're welcome you're welcome i tried we make
you look good all right no matt thanks for coming
back i actually watched his channel for the first
time after he plugged it here it's pretty good go
i keep typing in first cut that's not what it's
called it's called first coat it is called first
cut we're going film cut that's why we're
getting wrong yeah yeah yeah and i got it
i gotta write today obviously anyway guys we're
gonna watch episode three of obi-wan i'm very
excited for where we all are and yeah full
length watch longer as we sync up with the
time code are available over at our patreon for
super sexy rejects reaction highlights and watch
along is included at the same tier for some
exclusive shows as well if you can't do that
use the force to hit the like button it doesn't
you really require much for it but do it and
also subscribe and click that notification button
notified when our next reaction for obi-wan is up
and thanks to the boys of prepper probably set
down these highlights thank you to you too for
listening to me ramble and also uh follow ace
on uh film film theory all right let's get to
yeah it don't make me kill you
i do not fear the dark side
through the lies of the jedi
it's like watching the terminator get
assembled is this a daily process for
darth vader it must be oh we can't get darth vader
been looking for you for a long time
he's coming master
oh [__] vader's castle
i love it i have been watching
you third sister prove yourself
and the position of grand inquisitor is yours
fail me and you will not live
to regret it sorry yes sir
it looks so good oh this is what
we wanted just obi-wan invader
can't you make this thing go any faster it's
a trade route layer i'm not in control of it
can't you use the force on it or something that's
not how the force works that's not how it works
have you ever been afraid of the dark
how does it feel when you
turn on the light i feel safe
it feels like that drugs make me feel that
way we better get ready we're on approach
it feels like cinematic cutscenes from
a good star wars video game this whole
show feels that way to be coordinates
say the meeting point is further north
that is if our new friend was telling the truth
why would he lie people are not all good leia
damn snapping seems like
a losing battle these days
whoa oh he is people aren't all good stay close
this performance is so good so layered really good
have you guys played uh jedi paul on order yeah
i was gonna say i know something once in a while
i know star wars i know this place
this is dope though it's crazy sick now it feels
especially like a cut scene from a video here
i traced the manifest we should send out all
remaining probes now you are not in charge here oh
that seat is mine not yours it's already sitting
inside i just spoke with lord vader he asked me
to lead the hunt send out the probes do it now
i will get what i deserve and so was you i will
have two chairs i certainly hope so i'm getting to
think they really killed off the ground inquisitor
i'll be back
or it was all a big part of
the plan to get them oh yeah
get the wheels turned in here
it's a cool call back to uh empire with the
probe droids being shot out never seen that one
maybe they're just late i never
should have trusted him we don't
know if maybe no one is coming here leia well
if we're on our own we're gonna need some help
what are you doing
leia the hitchhiker we're looking for the
nearest port well i'm going that way jump
in oh no that's all right thank you we just need
directions come on father we've walked long enough
thanks frank my pleasure hop in i can't wait to
eat them are you trying to figure out whose voice
it is yeah who is that i have no idea it almost
sounds a little like jeff garland but it sounds a
little like seth rogen too well seth rogen yeah
bob chapic but i doubt it personally came down
oh great
play chill man
oh god
they're moving us around looking for
a jedi i hope we're not in any danger
oh no we'll find them we always do
we're smart
it's not like he's wearing jedi rose we always
hit our target boy he also says with a little girl
probably wondering hey you two haven't seen
anybody match that description have you
what are you doing out here that's a long story
it's a long way that sucks see the place where
he met my mother of course she she's not with us
anymore do you have any information about a jedi
i would know one if i saw one are you sure he's
even on this planet they know what they're doing
there ugh you called her leia i thought
her name was luma oh you listen that was
her mother's name i get confused sometimes
when i look at luma i see her mother's face
we all miss her very much hmm that was the
truth just keep your eyes open reported if
you see anything and i'm sorry for your loss i'm
not crying you're crying that was not a long way
are you my real father oh i wish i could say i was
but no i'm not sometimes i try
to imagine what he was like
he's a great guy as jedi were taken from our
families when we're very young i remember a
baby a baby yes i think i had a brother i
really don't remember him carl kenobi rick
can we get off here oh it's a standard inspection
don't worry won't take long i know these fellas
before they a couple of strays i found i
thought you might want to check them out
let me make myself look more like a jedi
where are you headed uh back
to tall we have family here
we were visiting all right step out
of the vehicle initiate protocol 23.
um
oh no put it down all right
i'm putting it down nah you
can't hit her dude i'm putting it down just
let it go
pretty sure you still could have gone around
it on oh god awesome i mean get down get down
i thought he was going to
go nuts put your head down
she's one of them
wow here we go they'll have sent a transmission
we have to hurry i'll take you the rest of the way
love interest i'll inform lord vader
he's already been informed he was most
appreciative he gave me his number
but we both know he'll be standing by his side
when this is over the actual grand inquisitor
nobody goes in or out do you understand me go
the bickering quality does feel plucked out of
rebels he gave you the right coordinates i was
on my way when the probes arrived but you'd
already gone i hadn't expected anyone to come
that's cause you're being negative i didn't mean
to run away i used to do it all the time i just
it was just for fun it wasn't your fault
oh l0la 59. well less say hello uh he's
he's just a loader they don't allow them to
communicate but what if he has something to say
appreciate how much he loves
respects the life of droids so much
i really like that aspect you're not
the first jedi to come through here
it all leads to jabim from there we give them
new identities and get them out [__] i witness
protection quinlan was here yeah he helps now and
again smuggling youngling wow that's a call back
quinlan boss father of eric boss from new
rockstars yeah definitely great man only
when the eyes are closed can you truly see see
what the way this is the way open up in there
i said open up you get back into meditating
open up now i think this church is going to
go ahead it starts to mess them up master chief
jedi was seen entering this camp you seen anyone
hey i'm talking to you oh my god yes do it
doesn't understand come on let's try the next one
kick your ass man kick your ass he's
like you're lucky mess you up dog
compromise we're coming to
you right now i don't care
get the [__] ready hurry she's in game of
thrones mm-hmm opposite pedro pascal yeah yeah
trying to place it yeah she's also in uh
luther why do you do this risk everything
i joined up when the empire stood for something by
the time i realized what they really were it was
too late i made some mistakes we
all did it's a fascinating role
what is it
he's in your mind
oh no oh wow oh we're making a
house call where's that video sound
this is cool i love seeing
him like on another planet
wow this is such a mind [__] for
obi-wan hmm
oh my goodness whoa
oh
awesome you think he's trying to call him out yeah
he's trying to miss people jump in and help yeah
yeah yeah i think he's gonna do it
promise me oh damn i take them away
damn bro this is amazing
dude he is so sick he's like
forcing his hand he's sadistic
oh
oh here we go
oh man it's lit that thing
up in a long time just do it
i want him to do it so bad dory he's
running for the perfect moment to do it
yes he knows just as well as we
do it's gotta be a good moment
that was perfect actually
he did it so crispy man
come on balance yourself out man cook him cook him
you have to help him he'll be fine nope he
won't be i can make it on my own from here
oh
the ears have made you weak
he's just like taunting him go keep running till
you reach the port a pilot will meet you there
oh a fad film coming to life man you should
have killed me when you had the chance
forced aside for you everyone thought he did
this is like a gold mine for an inquisitor
oh god damn
he really wants him to burn like he did wow
your pain has just begun
surprising looking all right in that
fire yeah so far bring him to me damn
oh clutch droid
it's so cool seeing him through the fire that
uplighting like a monster movie i do like seeing
vader capture through this camera work so much
it looks really cool it's really really cool man
that's a cool shot that all right flames
the eyes damn this is a pretty brutal
ass vader it's the punishment
vader you're going to be okay
oh i think rival's gonna get her don't be
afraid yeah come closer are you the one i'm
supposed to meet unfortunately they couldn't
make it but i'll take you from here oh damn
[__] damn that was great i really i really
was a great one that was a great episode
i only took four people to write that
that was a really great episode yeah yeah
best one so far yeah this was the show i've
been watching yeah i know you love everything
in anything star wars this is the episode i
was like yeah this is the show i've been
wanting right here i still love the first
one but this is this is another great one
yeah it's on it's not another level of me
now this compared to the other two
oh wait wait vivian letter player moses
sing group son kane constantly saying his
lines differently every time oh snap
she's right killstead from zac braff
is that who that was yeah i could hear it now yeah
james earl jones that's great james rowe jones
and hayden christensen may be in the suit
hey pedro pascal's barely on that set
director photography that's uh the korean guy
i forgot what movie he did but that's why he
looks so cool cause he was uh he was the one
they they hired years ago man i'm gonna look him
up right now if that's okay with you guys um whoa
whoa it's not like it's not like we're gonna
jump cut here must be within your brain all right
no that's not him
we'll come back with that information and
high four three definitely what all right gang
dudes my dudes that was a really satisfying
episode this is exactly what i wanted to be i'm
covered in cat hair right now i just had a cat on
me a moment ago um but i thought this was really
gripping this was exceptionally gripping watching
vader at this more brutal standpoint is something
that i wanted i just want them to go even harder
that's what i found myself there like a harsher
drag them through blow their heads up
really good dude do something gnarly
just go bananas i want to see like that version
of vader and i love this you know we've seen
aggressive vape in terms of live action we've seen
like aggressive vader mournful vader about this is
like rageful vader yeah i really like it a lot of
like rogue one right it felt like the rogue one
a little bit well they had the rogue one
fight but more than just a fight like when
he's talking to riva or just going through
the town and torturing innocent people just
like what that i want that obi-wan that rise
out of give me obi-wan you know come on out like
the crooked the crooked bad boy coming through
town the uh the next snap the force neck snap
was cool so cool like some
stranger things [__] right there
yeah that's what i mean i want to see like more of
that i i really enjoyed it i think you know evan
mcgregor just keeps killing it but really quick
while we're on vader what i loved about the vader
performance is like yeah getting james earl's
jones voice james earls james james is earl james
jones's voice and back um how it's like getting
that performance uh but you can still feel hey
i don't know if it's hayden christensen always
underneath it but you can still feel that version
of anakin skywalker like when you watch you
know the original trilogy you don't really get
a sense of you know the of a hayden christian sin
underneath the suit um or hating christensen type
even yet here you can feel that and it elevates it
that much more and i love the way they capture him
here because this is the first time you see vader
caught in this kind of camera movement like a
lot of this just feels like raw you know a lot of
those are handheld and simple landscapes at times
um it feels like when you watch those van films
that and this is i mean this complementary wax
cause you could depending on the the tone or slang
and how you say it when you say fan film that can
sound like an insult i mean complimentary wise of
when you watch those great fan films those grippy
ones and you're like damn this would be a cool
thing why doesn't disney do [__] like this and
then this is the stuff where i'm like yeah that's
what i want to see more of that you know like when
he's torturing obi-wan and the fire like he just
it's been 10 years he's just like i hate my life
i need to punish this guy for what
he's done to me um it's awesome stuff
ace what happened hold on second last
time you hey she go second there's a ghost
oh i go first okay um yeah vader was incredible i
mean the idea of vader touching down and getting
his hands dirty and doing the dirty work and not
just leaving it to riva and the inquisitors was
a really cool concept too i love seeing vader
in this terrain something that we've never seen
before at least not in like canon uh we've never
seen vader like touchdown on the planet like this
before we've obviously seen him in hoth when
he came down there for that brief moment which
is a cool moment on empire strikes back and then
for the rest of pretty much the original trilogy
we see vader on ships and on different star
destroyers but we don't really see him touched
down too many times unless it's like a video
game or something so that was really cool for me
uh seeing the lighting of the light i don't
know if you guys caught with the lighting of the
lightsaber oh yeah it's really cool illuminates
this this just their specific like yeah little
surrounding this like circle that we're in the
circumference room yeah uh to finish my point
that i was saying at the end of the video chung
uh chun kung chung uh who is the dp for old boy
dp for the handmaiden uh he did last night in soho
he did a lot of other movies but he is a very very
good dp that's why this episode looked like [__]
yeah that's why it looked incredible yeah i really
am convinced that's why it looks so good because
we have a veteran uh director of photography
doing the majority of the shots so i felt like
that came out quite a bit when it came to the
lighting in the shot selection yeah i bet freaking
obi-wan even mcgregor's performance like when he
when the first time he sees uh anik or he thinks
he sees anakin because he's kind of like tripping
balls there was a whole realization of because
he's this whole time he's thought he's killed
him you know and living with the pain of that and
everything surrounding him is just a reminder of
that this whole the whole even though he thought
anakin was dead the birth of what the empire is he
feels i imagine that he feels like partially
responsible for for it before never having
had the foresight to prevent anakin from going
down that path and what it led to and all that
so the first time he sees him and then
when he senses him when they're in what's
that planet called that they're in at
the end here oh my puzzle mario puzo
uh yeah and then that the that distorted
sidewinding shot of him it just looks like
he's about to faint like just getting hit with
the presence of anakin like he could just feel
it sensing it um i'm trying to hand this off to
you without taking over john it's all good they've
done it no i think they've done i think my perhaps
favorite thread that they've put into the tone of
this show is that amount of foreboding and dread
and viciousness or monstrousness that comes off of
basically the the entire dark side presence
here and even two i'll include the obi-wan
because there is such a buildup with you know
the igniting of his lightsaber but two i mean
we we've remarked on the previous episodes how
much they're not going hog wild with lightsaber
stuff they're really making those things you know
they're they're making them rewarding by building
them up in such a way where at first when like you
have riva and him squaring off it's just like this
monstrous buzzing force and then here you have all
that build up to them finally clashing together
and yeah this onset of of dread and of just
disturbance within that comes with the arrival
and the presence of vader like i like the subtle
hints there's better disturbance than the force
yeah and i like the way i i believe i can't
remember where i heard this clarification but
i think it's in one of the like the novelization
of revenge of the sith where they say like you
know obi-wan left it to the force as to whether
anakin would live or die there and i like that
you have this sort of question it's like yeah he
assumes he's probably dead but he doesn't know for
certain and there's almost like this ghost story
um mixed little hint of just demonic presence that
comes with the entire situation surrounding anakin
and i think the way that they captured him here
really it's like you said it puts you there in a
lot of different ways partly due to the handheld
nature partly peering through the flames they do
a lot really nicely with foreground obstruction to
make it feel like you are really there looking at
this you know person and also too seeing somebody
like obi-wan who we have such an association
with being this warm safe presence much like
the force says he describes here is actually not
is actually completely sort of on his heels and is
you know terrified in a way of what is coming
and i like even though they're not making a
huge big deal out of it directly that yeah there
is so much disturbance within obi-wan right now
and that's one of the the main highlight of the
show for me i mean it's been like vader being
badass the whole time every time vader's there i
mean like we can see invaders uh castle oh my god
oh so i have to talk about that because that was
so cool i mean the idea of just like zooming in
on the lava and then working its way up the camera
working its way up to vader's castle and obviously
we know about vader's castle we saw it in rogue
one as well but it's it's seen it again and seen
more of the inside of it and seen the throne room
which looks incredible which has a view of all of
mustafar in the back almost like he wants to like
remember and almost like you know remind himself
of what happened and what he is and how he became
what he was been a motive for of his this entire
time yeah it really is kind of this crazy concept
of like the most traumatic moment in his life is
also when he became who he is now which is vader
and he almost wants to live in that moment and
live in that planet and it's just a really cool
set design and it's a really cool concept to see
that invader i think that's what's making vader
so compelling this time around more than before
for me because vader's always been great but
what makes him especially compelling is that
he's a character you could feel all the pain and
the tortured soul underneath the suit this time
around where normally it's like you had hayden
christensen's performance and then darth vader was
just you know badass i mean there was other shades
that you would be getting like empire strikes back
and turn the jedi of course but here this is like
a real to merciless performance here and then you
back that with obi-wan's resigned performance the
or know mcgregor's what and by the way you know
i know i was like a little bit critical of the
actress who played leia before because it just
more of the writing of the character because i had
a feeling it had something more to do with that
but i thought leia was actually really great
this episode i really thought she was great and
and i liked that we got more shades of her she
felt way more human and not just like you know
uh precocious child actor like she felt like a
real human character and i i really sympathize
with her i just wanna throw that out really fast
but um well curious to get um anyone's thoughts
on this one the lightsaber fight here because
i think what a lot of people might be expecting
is you know like revenge of the sith had one of
the most epic balls to the wall like a lightsaber
fight that just went on for like 45 minutes it was
like just a crazy choreographed fight and that's
not where we're gonna get um maybe something close
to that maybe down the road but of course not the
beginning and i thought what was cool about this
reintroduction of it because we were all like once
obi-wan going to ignite his lightsaber and so much
about uh you know when discussing the force is so
much about feeling you know and when he sees ob uh
darth vader for the first i mean he's confronted
with darth vader you know it's like he whip he
holds up the handle of the lightsaber or what
do you call not the handle what was that called
the hilt that's what it's called good word uh the
hilt of the lightsaber and we think he's gonna
ignite it but he doesn't and then he gets that
instinctual feeling eventually and does it without
thinking and that to me is more as opposed to
making this big grandiose moment of when he does
ignite it that's more uh authentic and in line
with what they when they talk about with the force
and i like the fight because it was so emotionally
taunting versus crazy choreography like vader just
exuded power and dominance over him the whole time
it was just like kind of bullying you know what
i mean yeah you watch obi-wan's struggle and he
even makes that remark like well you really are in
bad shape everyone which you get the sense almost
like even even though i mean his goal obviously
is to bring him in and have you know whatever
you know uh way he wants to punish him i almost
feel like there's a small hint of like i mean
i can't break in like this you gotta rise to the
occasion a little more for the history that we
both share but two i mean just the way that
they like you said before the way that they
enhance the colors like i love as much as people
gripe about the shows on disney plus especially
being you know very desert oriented and whatnot i
thought it was nice to have this fight take place
in sort of a neutral ground from you know the last
famous fight was obviously mustafar lava heroes we
have the crystalline version of that just sand but
you also have the darkness with which the actual
glow can illuminate things and i love the fact
they let so much of that play in just the sound
effects and in that glowing because you have those
two striking strong complementary colors which is
cool from a filmmaking standpoint because you
know they had to light that put the lightsabers
in after but it's also just a great visual
color representation of the clash at hand
yeah i mean the lighting is obviously
amazing when it comes to the fight itself
it's interesting because i keep thinking about
timeline wise as far as what they're going to do
i'm pretty sure they're doing two seasons
right is that what they said for this i have
no idea i thought this was just a or it could be
a word it could be a one-off but but my thing is
two seasons okay so my thing is like eventually
we're gonna get to a point where we see
a much more improved ob1 um because obviously i
keep going back to the line from a new hope but
it's important because it's it's a very famous
line from a new hope as far as implying that
you know last time we faced you know you were
you were the master but now i'm the master um
so he was says i'm but the luna but you are the
master um so for me it's like i get that [__]
i know i messed up [__] i messed the whole thing
up right now uh but for me it's more like you know
eventually we are going to get an obi-wan who is
a little bit more confident in who he is and his
abilities and again if you've seen rebels you've
seen that scene with darth maul which eventually
shows that he is much more connected to the force
than he is now which obviously he's very much out
of shape but not there but it still was a cool
like brief moment it was very one-sided but it
was still like a cool like little brief moment
of like teasing what could be as far as if once
obi-wan is like you know in god mode well i think
what they're doing with obi-wan that i find really
really cool like it really started to click with
me in this episode because yeah we will get that
ob whenever we just have to would it make sense
if we didn't get it obi-wan down that road and
we have to see his arc um because right now he
is so like he is so there's so much destitute
he is so resigned and he doesn't want he's like
snapping at leia left and right over anything
that's like hey this might be a positive thing no
nothing's positive everything's evil in this world
everything that happens he just snaps um he's
lost all hope uh basically for anything good
because he's a shattered guy right now and
this is slowly putting him on little paths
where he can regain that light like you with the
metaphor he talked about we're like are you scared
of the dark and then the light comes on and you
feel safe and he's slowly get getting that light
back in him from interacting with leia and then
seeing um the the path is what it's called yeah
yeah the yeah the play where they find like
force sensitive kids and or like help help
get people out of there it's like smuggle uh you
know it's like the underground railroad you know
yeah um so that sympathizers yeah so they have uh
so like seeing that and then seeing who else has
crossed paths there what's so neat is that he's
obviously so traumatized by his experience that
happened with anakin skywalker that through
confronting through having to confront vader
through having to you know go through these
altercations with him again this experience
is what's going to get him to be back in tune with
the force you know facing his darkest thing ever
is going to be the thing that brings him the light
again and i love that and it just has to go that
path and i'm okay knowing that or at least having
a good guest as to that and i'm okay with that
because that's just a beautiful story to tell and
and it does it does reestablish as it necessitates
as a gap for obi-wan for a live action that
we haven't gotten from prequels to modern day
trilogy you know yeah and i feel like a lot of it
too is going to come back to qui-gon which we keep
getting teased uh throughout the entire season
so far we've had three episodes and i think he's
mentioned him in all three episodes definitely
talked to him yeah or tried to attract him in the
attack of the clone's revenge but but i feel
like that's important because i think that's
going to help him connect to his next chapter and
his next step obviously you know force ghost but
also just connecting to the force in general when
it comes to his abilities and when it comes to his
contact with the force um and obviously overcoming
anakin and overcoming who he is as vader and and i
think i don't know i think coming to terms with it
right because i feel like by a new hope he's come
to terms with like oh definitely anakin's gone
this is vader now i have to you know be at peace
with that and that's not all on me yeah and i feel
like a lot of that's gonna come from qui-gon well
i think he probably i mean qui-gon left him with
the response the role to i'm dying you gotta this
guy's chosen one you gotta put him on the path
and he prob he probably feels like he completely
failed qui-gon and that also haunts him that's
why i love you mcgregor's performance here because
you know i know there's a lot of cool no i
don't want to get his whole debate on the
last jedi i'm sick of that [__] conversation and
there's a lot of debating about you know uh luke
skywalker and all that and how he was portrayed
and they do something kind of similar here but
we can it it all makes sense based off of
everything we know that came before the show
you know yeah this guy totally would be in this
spot in his life at this point yeah based on
what we know that's a very fluid decision rather
than a oh oh that's a choice yeah yeah definitely
and and two just like i loved watching him and
and the young actress who plays leia like go
back and forth too like there was so such natural
interplay between them like you brought up before
i think that really helped to kind of bring
everything together for that performance too
what do you think about ace specifically how do
you feel about the inquisitors because they're
i like i was excited about the inquisitors i'm not
a big fan of the way they're being portrayed to be
totally honest i mean i feel like they're they
they feel like they're part of the part of the
cartoon to me you know yeah but i don't know if
that's a bad thing i i kind of feel like that's
kind of what they're made for i don't think
they've ever necessarily been the most badass
yeah really bad necessarily i don't think they've
ever been in any kind of media that they've been
in unless it's grand inquisitor season one of
rebels that kind of felt like a big deal but
you know the other inquisitors from there on were
always like in teams and tag teams or like in
trios which kind of make it felt like you know
if they were so imposing you know one of them
could be a big deal but it's always in groups i i
don't i don't i feel like they're fulfilling the
role that they are tasked with and i feel like
they're doing a pretty good job with that so
i feel like i'm in the minority of people who
i've enjoyed riva thus far and i did too i do
too yeah and i feel like in this episode and
i feel like the part of it is that yeah i feel
like the rest of the inquisitors are a bit
you know like uh sun kang talks really slow
and king says every what which brother is he
again fifth brother yeah yeah um son kang he
says every line the same every eye every line
it's a lot like this and it takes a long time
to get them all out and so yeah like i i feel
like in a way i'm like okay that almost does
feel like a choice and yeah the rest of them are
kind of bickery and self-serving and power-hungry
and riva has a purpose beyond all that and a
connection to anakin i just think her presence
i i believe the menace in her presence or at least
like the seething anger that guides her she's not
as scary as darth vader but them together i'm like
yeah i'm a little threatened by them like when she
tracks down leia i'm like well that's not good you
know like whereas if it had been sung kang i'd be
like hey it'll be fine yeah leia can take sun king
yeah not not just light han or anything how do you
fee i mean i liked riva i've been a back
and forth on her performance specifically
but i liked her here on this particular i liked
everything about this episode but what did you
think about what do you think is going on with the
grand inquisitor here do you think that they're
you just like this is a thing that kind of mapped
out with vader to get to elevate the others yeah
i feel like this is just another like while this
guy is out of commission kind of thing we'll we
can make a new grand inquisitor if you fulfill
the task and if you prove that you're better
than this guy but obviously he's got to know he's
not dead yeah 100 100 for sure i just feel like
he's taking advantage of his like leave of absence
granted inquisitor was supposed to go on vacation
anyways they're like we'll come up with this ruse
that way riva could really rise to the right one
his uh his suspension he's been suspended for a
couple months he's been written up yeah he's you
know while he's out we need a new grand inquisitor
to fill the role uh i feel like that's kind of
what it is and it's funny because i actually kind
of like that scene because it's also very original
trilogy vader especially empire strikes back where
he's always trying to promote the next guy he's
definitely definitely he did it like three times
uh admiral pete shout out to mlp um but it's like
that's my boy oh some guy out there with an
emerald t-shirt is just shedding a single tear
but i feel like that's uh that's what vader
does right he's always kind of like the big boss
promoting people and demoting people and
killing people if they do a bad job and
it's like a running that was like a running joke
an empire like he kept like killing off people and
he kept like promoting them and i i feel like this
is kind of what he's doing now with the riva he's
just the worst manager all i know how to do is
promote or kill i don't know how to empower a team
i don't know what i'm doing guys i'm just
winging this lord vader over here darth
vader can i go to the bathroom no no stay on
the assembly line i will squeeze your bladder
yeah stranger stars um yeah i mean i i don't
really have anything more to add but is there
anything i mean the shout out to quinlan boss
that was cool um you know you jedi you're trying
to refresh my memory between takes and i was
like i do because i saw clone wars once yes
really quick watch yeah the only time i took my
time was the final season um that was the time i
i loved the final season but i would like binge
the [__] and then i just took my time in the
final season but i'm like so much of it is a blur
to me now yeah cuz i don't even like i'm like that
sounds so familiar i don't remember quinlan moss
yeah quinlan boss um obviously clone wars a lot
in the comics if you guys are in the comics um he
teamed up with obi wan to take on cad bane that
was a cool fight scene from from clone wars 2.
um yeah i mean he has a connection adventurous
if anyone is connected to that so if anyone knows
about that adventure's dead right she's dead by
this one yeah okay no too bad i liked veterans
i feel like we can get calcastas now ooh yes
because uh this takes around the same time period
too i think so as far as jedi fall in order to
yeah yeah i think i mean like that's what this
this whole thing with the path was like making
me go oh [__] man it really feels like we're
seeing the inquisitors which was [__] out of
jedi fallen order and then which is not anyway
but yeah but generally you have that and then
you have uh and then the thing with the path
like oh my god i'm getting jet i fall in order
fives right now has passed through there at some
point it would be great if we got calcastas he's
so that such a cool kid and then they announced
jed i fall in order too and you know how disney
is they're trying to line all their [__] up so
yeah i feel like that that would be great if we
can get calcasa i think that would just make fans
lose their [__] that's like the next stage right
like we're getting cartoon characters brought
to life now let's get the video game characters
that'd be amazing it'd be a really cool like
you know shout out to anyone who plays the video
games because i feel like that's a you know media
that doesn't really get acknowledged too too much
and i also want to say really fast um even though
i've been critical of riva's performance it has
nothing to do with the fact that she's black i've
been watching i went on uh social media talking
about heavy spoilers about this and apparently
i've just been so blind if we were talking about
this before we filmed i was like apparently i've
been soap because you've known about it for months
i've been so blind to all this like crazy amount
of sometimes people say it's racism when it's like
not people are being some people are just critical
of stuff and then there's other part where
people are just saying straight up racist [__]
full on racist [__] and that [__] just i don't
know why we're still there with a lot of the fan
bases star wars like this is [__] bananas to me
that we can what is supposed to be like just
a bunch of aliens robots and white people
like you see yes that's that's kind of what
they want yeah it's [__] ridiculous and um
i i i'm rooting for moses it's maybe roofer moses
ingram that much more because you'll see these
some of these youtubers thumbnails of the [__]
they say on them i couldn't believe it and uh
i think it's just so such a shame and [__]
disgusting and um and for all you star wars
fans out there who think you're on the rebel
side when you're doing [__] like that maybe
reconsider your entire moral compass i'm
not talking about people who don't like the
character or like we're just like i don't like the
character i'm not a big fan of performance that's
like a completely different conversation there is
some straight-up racism out there and that [__]
just needs to end man yeah i mean if i'm being
honest i i feel like it's it's been a part of
star wars obviously for for a while now it really
stood out a lot when it came to the force awakens
and john boyega's character uh there came
this huge wave of online criticism towards
any co-lead not even lead like just co-lead
black character that was a part of the
star wars franchise and this stuff with
moses ingram i really encourage people
if you aren't a fan of the character or if you
are a little bit more critical of the performance
to try and not just give it a
chance but to try and reconsider
perspectives on what comes from that right is
your perspective coming from a place of watching
the show or is your perspective coming from any
of these online videos that you may be watching
because i do feel like that has an influence and
these online creators who have a negative platform
create that negative atmosphere and can create a
negative perspective that's kind of what happened
with the last jedi sorry guys um a lot of people
came out of the movie theater and they were like
yeah that was pretty good and then they saw
videos and they're like i don't like it anymore
um in fact i hate it yeah and i felt like i i
ran into so many people who reacted like that
and when it comes to this i for one
have always been outspoken as far as
racist star wars fans which is a a part of the
for you know the franchise and the fans and i feel
like people saying that we shouldn't acknowledge
or we should ignore this i don't think ignoring
it is the way to go i think acknowledging
it pointing it out and condemning it is the
way to go and as much as we want to say that the
majority of the fan base is not racist we should
still acknowledge that there is a lot that are
racist and they are very vocal and very persuasive
uh so i really do encourage people to defend moses
anytime you get a chance to really just stand up
and to be on the right side of this
because come on guys this has been
way too long and we cannot be standing for this
so yeah yeah and i mean not every time a person
who's not a white person shows up is some kind
of mathematical you know attempt to white men too
yeah white man is like if there's anybody other
than that there's some kind of reason for uproar
and sometimes it's just like hey different kinds
of people exist and could fill various roles
and if you want a diverse galaxy that really
feels like it's of another world where there's
tons and tons and tons of people and and species
overlapping what's what's the problem it's it's
i hate the i just hate this part like we make a
lot of jokes uh about that side of the of that
vocal part of the internet that screams culture
and everything you know uh we make a lot of like
satirical jokes about that but truthfully there
isn't a lot of jokes because that should just
honestly annoys the [__] out of me it just
it pisses me off that the second they hear
of of somebody it that suddenly there's an agenda
but i'm like not one part of this show has made
about riva being black to begin with like yeah
it doesn't even it's not even the point of the
character it's not like they're making some
social commentary about it that's the thing
it's like it's like wait for the text of the
thing you're complaining about to actually be
disingenuous in trying to incorporate some kind
of progressive message before just decrying oh
my god they're ruining my favorite whatever and
for what star wars is about to be to have racism
so like about fans surrounding it is is like
anti-star wars to me it's the most anti-service
thing i don't know how many times i have to
say that if you are very much anti you know
progress anti-progressive anti-scene diversity
then you are anti-star wars sorry not star wars
star wars has always been about overcoming
this empirical standpoint of seeing everything
uniform and everything one way the whole
point of the rebellion and having freaking
characters like lando be the one
to take out the second death star
uh with the freaking sullustan in nine nub was
to show these two guys who are communicating
in different languages and still taking down the
most powerful machine on the planet that's that's
a very very progressive moment in star wars and
i feel like george lucas if you know anything
about george lucas or read up anything on him you
will know that that is exactly what he's trying
to communicate so again that's not star wars yeah
i don't i wasn't planning on bringing that up but
just came out of here like this is a thing
that's happening the only people allowed to
vanquish myspace nazis are other white people okay
i'm just gonna say i think it needs to be said
i will i i mean the last thing i'll say is i think
is the odd part about it is people i don't think
often realize that's the thing with like a lot
of real racism is they don't realize that they're
being racist they just think it's a point of view
they have about a certain thing without realizing
and then they blame like agenda virtue signaling
something else without them realizing oh wait i'm
actually being pretty racist about this right now
especially with the fact that i just said a racist
thing right now because a lot of it has been
very overt in in the way it's been said about her
that so much of the star wars freaking social
media had to come out and say something i'm like
because yeah it was pretty bad um oh yeah
that tweet from the actual star wars yeah
there was some like really nasty once i saw like
youtube thumbnails saying [__] i was like oh no
this is ridiculous anyway guys um if you're not
one of those people subscribe to this channel
we just lost we go under a million subs like how
many people worth a lot of racist subscribers
that's weird they must have
all thought you were white
yeah no that is this is a star wars video yeah
you never know i'd rather put that out put that
honest thought out there and lose subs if that
means we can get wean out some of those people um
but then when the camera's not rolling oh
my god the numbers are dead oh no we have
to go back whoa culture's ruining everything no
good comments about riva from now on guys okay
if you do have to talk
about riva's complaints only
all right we gotta do a
patron of the day shout out
chris wham-off coming in at the last minute of may
thank you so much for pledging to our patreon page
again buddy it's been a while since i've heard
of you but i feel like it's really fitting to
shout you out on obi-wan because let's face it if
there was someone who really really really didn't
actually have the feelings to
help out someone but was asked to
and would do it because they were asked to because
they knew it would be the right thing to do
it's 100 you there's no one just that good a guy
you're just that good a guy you do more community
service work than anyone i know that includes
not just people on patreon but anyone i know in
real life too so chris it's great to have a soul
like yours at our patreon page don't don't have
enough people like you in my life so i'm grateful
that you would support us for as long as you have
and uh thank you for being you man and um i hope
one day we can't meet a person where you'll treat
us to dinner because we're not you and we are
stingy i like to spend more than like ten dollars
on another person on myself i'll spend boatloads
but on another person not much money but for
for us you know like i know you'll treat
us good man i know you'll i know you'll
go on the negatives for us i know you'll max
out that credit card we deserve your charity
so thank you chris for willing to go
broke to support us people who don't
need your money but we'll gladly just take
it because we're us chris love you buddy